hi I'm Evan Carmichael I believe in
entrepreneurs and I believe that i live
in the greatest city in the world to be
an entrepreneur toronto canada and city
so to show some love support my my local
city i'm going to be starting a new
series called n city where I'm profiling
showcasing getting some advice wisdom
support from local entrepreneurs I'm
standing here in the corner of yonge and
sheppard means where it all begins I'm
gonna be walking to local businesses to
to get their advice and I'm starting off
with an organization called enterprise
Toronto they are a group that is funded
by the City of Toronto that their
mission support local entrepreneurs in
the city and I couldn't think of a
better way to start so let's go meet
their program manager Sandy gold walk to
the location and you guys can join in on
the fun here we go
hi I'm sandy I'm one of the business
advisors here at enterprise Toronto in
the North York office so tell me about
Enterprise Toronto enterprise Toronto is
a resource for entrepreneurs like
yourself we cater to everybody young and
old debt doesn't matter if you're 18 it
doesn't matter if you're 89 we're a
walk-in Resource Center where you can
come in and get information on how to
start a business planning financials
sales and marketing so anything you need
to know about starting a business you
can find here at enterprise Toronto you
can do anything you personally why do
you pick helping entrepreneurs I come
from a family of entrepreneurs I find
that starting a business takes a lot of
two nation a lot of patience and I don't
personally possess those skills myself
so this gives me the opportunity to help
people who do so I get the best of both
worlds how do we first meet here at
enterprise Toronto I recruited you to do
a youth chat at our business forum right
so every year in the price Rana does
this awesome event downtown and they
have all these experts come in and in
sandy tapped me to come in and give
advice I got swarmed i remember it was
only socially for like an hour or
something and then and then people kept
like I gotta go I gotta go to some other
event that people kept giving me cards
and I was fun though this year we had a
over 2000 people attend so great that
you guys put this stuff on every year
Enterprise Toronto in one word helpful
what are you most proud of in your work
with enterprise trial we run a few
programs that I'm really proud of one is
starter company it's a small micro grant
then that helps young entrepreneurs
start a business or grow their business
we provide training and mentoring next
is summer company to teach students that
instead of going out to say the gap and
getting a job for the summer why not try
self-employment so they can receive a
grant for up to three thousand dollars
to give self-employment a try and also
we are a community partner future
printer Canada which is also loan for
youth we extend the term youth in this
program to up to 39 years old so I
really like that and that's a I still
fit into that category
yay being able to meet with somebody see
their ideas see their vision and see it
actually come into reality and track
them through their process is really
gratifying is there one story that comes
to mind that is you're really proud of I
get to do this job you know there's oh
my gosh there's so many if I could just
think of one it was a chiropractor give
a shadow to massage matters and he's a
chiropractor opened up a massage therapy
clinic and chiropractic clinic in the
Toronto area and in the span of a short
year was able to launch this business
it's a beautiful beautiful location that
they have and he employs I think gosh I
think six employee so really really
inspiring to see a young person come in
here get some information get a business
plan together secure funding go through
the whole process of getting a property
going through the renovations going
through all the logistics of the City of
Toronto and hiring his employees and
walking in his front door and seeing him
in business and in action and you know
watching his employees really respect
him and thought wow that's pretty cool
the people watch you don't know in a
price trono it's a free service hate for
the taxpayers of Toronto part of why
Toronto is the best city in the world to
be an entrepreneur right for people who
are starting up what do you think is
kind of the biggest problem that they
face and and what advice do you give
them to help can overcome that I think
most people are not aware of everything
they need to be aware we have first
people who come in who will for example
want to open up a restaurant but don't
have an idea that to open a restaurant
you actually need to have I in addition
to having your business registered a
municipal operating license a food
handle or certification health Toronto
or whatever city you're with all these
things they don't realize our that come
into play so the best thing to do is to
come into Resource Center like ours
educate yourself about your industry and
planning as well another theme I explore
often on the channel is one about the
little man and the little man is the
person who
we tells you your idea is not gonna work
and sometimes you could be your own
little man right they look at themselves
in the mirror and say Who am I to do
this you know they have those moments of
doubt what would you tell someone how to
overcome that beat the little man yeah a
very common theme what I could recommend
for that is there's so many networking
opportunities so I would say surround
yourself with like-minded people who are
in the same thought process and I think
it'll definitely elevate I love the word
elevate too I love elevate that could be
Enterprise Ranas word elevate what kind
of advice would you give to an
entrepreneur who's applying for any of
these funding programs we received just
a you know an incredible amount of
applications for a really finite number
of spaces so all of our applicants are
have really great idea so it's really
hard to filter through them but we do
look for certain criteria so my biggest
piece of advice is think of it as an
interview I can only you know ascertain
what's in your was in your application
we do assess on things like liability so
if you have existing clients or if you
have clients that are guaranteed let let
us know that put that in your
application if you've invested a certain
amount of personal funds let us know
that you've done that if you've had you
know some press exposure if you've had
some articles written about you put
those links in your application it
really will highlight a prompt to
further look into the application talk
about marketing let us know that you're
serious so we look at viability we look
at the level of seriousness and we look
at the level of commitment so again the
more information that you can put into
an application that increases your
chances because I can only assess the
situation with the information that we
see sandy thank you so much for the time
and looking forward to seeing this go
live so if you guys are watching this
you have a comment you have a question
you leave in the comment section below
thank you guys so much for watching and
we'll see you soon continue to believe
sign up for the newsletter for more
believe
you